thank you everybody
welcome to meme review the place where
we have fun memes review trivia and
learn more info and fun facts about
memes
[Applause]
I especially like this mean because it's
it's it's a fun to settle a predatory
theme I can really not think of any
other better track that to be played
during my funeral and where is Obama
where has he gone and why is pretty pair
of you in this meme now when it's three
months old
post the video post the video and then
read the text god it's nothing funny
about that I think I find it allowed to
do the poor guy dance if I do it really
slowly I can do it by you can't even see
you can't even see you
what the Frick this this song is the
perfect it's a perfect mashup of
happiness and sadness there's really no
other way to put it it's the Alpha and
the Omega
anytime anything bad happens in your
life
you know what to do it's time to hit it
to this son and his loved ones died why
cry about it when you can just have an
epic crab party about it why I meant any
actual real emotions when you can just
hide them through memes do I have any
coherent thought in general there's
always just a meme a click away
how old is 9 agree
okay that's epic scientists have broken
down
what makes this something so special why
this song out of all songs in the whole
entirety of you the universe what makes
it so special
the crab meat gets of course a solid
it's a solid seven point poor pretty
good sorry though it's over bye-bye crab
bye-bye
no more crab means dancing for you
consider this mean just as dead as my
emotions thank you very much for your
service crab mean it's been a pleasure
come on
this is a very important announcement we
talked about this last week but the EU
have made a new little rule so don't say
it don't say think it don't say it don't
think it don't say it the n-word okay
I told me I freaking told you guys last
time and look at this what the Frick
goggle is racist goggle nagger why I
didn't know Google was raised how can
the biggest company say the n-word what
the that's almost as bad as the biggest
youtuber oh you're not convinced yet not
convinced yet you're still thinking
about it
it can you can you can't look look look
what happened to my fellow friend
youtuber The Annoying Orange
don't say it don't think it okay
remember and be kind to each other and
now a word from our sponsor that's right
everybody and please rest assured just
because we have a sponsor that doesn't
that's not gonna change meme review okay
it's not the money and fame is not gonna
go to our heads here override meme
review everything will stay the same
don't worry guys we'll always bring that
dankest memes okay even though we have
nanny are sponsoring this video
thank you guys so much check out ninja
in the description enter the code ninja
and next me David brought David I mean I
know you're a sophisticated guy the
world is a mess the world is as angry as
it gets
well you think this is gonna cause a
little more anger
the world is an angry place this just in
on a special meme review pew new segment
Donald Trump is a gamer I think this is
really gonna turn some heads and really
change some minds what do you guys think
as always passing the question on to you
guys okay okay alright this this one me
cool stick my dog fan my dog
John wick in need of a gold scar my
mom's credit card info me 2018 means
just summarize just put a text on it
cannibalism would solve both
overpopulation and world hunger me a
normal stop adding text to every goddamn
image you find on the Internet okay
fifth-grader turning off youtube
autoplay teach some demon dude sword
night what the Frick what I don't get
that one more car
DFC Fame and recognition this me what
the Frick is this you don't recognize
the artist on meme review what is this
don't worry guys we're not running low
on memes at all
okay I got ton of great stuff I got so
much great stuff coming up there I mean
with you so how about this one wooden
stock synthetic stock laughing stock
selector community those people are dumb
right idiots okay okay okay all right
sorry sorry go away that site go man not
say all right how about this one all
right being red piss come wait a minute
wait a minute
wait the Freak who made this meme guys
can we please this is super important
whoever made this mean can we try and
contact whoever made this me because I'm
pretty sure that pissin come is not
supposed to be red so I think he could
actually or she could be a big poppy
Harlow here with another special news
segment a new Smash Brothers Super Smash
brother
character have been announced that's
right hackers have figured out go to
smash bros comm if you don't think this
is real click on their Korean thing hit
translate click on fighter scroll down
and there you have it Jack elation salt
the new character can't wait to play us
him I think I wonder what his moves here
I'm so glad they haven't announced Louie
waluigi yet because a jackal asian
salted it's really who i've been waiting
for he's really the character that i
think you know i was on the offense
before if I should actually buy this
game or not but now I'm super onboard
the day with that with a what is this
RPG this is super important serious guys
can we get some serious music going ok I
have a freaking question to you guys
when you this is personal is for real I
want you to answer this honestly in the
comments
preferably so I get more comments
never a for other okay for science when
you walk up the stairs or down the
stairs behind resentiment do you walk
one step or two steps
because a new science data has shown
that people who walk down two stairs at
a time are way stronger way more
powerful way smarter it's basic you
might if you walk one stair step at a
time
you might as well just consume put so
it's so a write up your book you might
as well put soy right into your
bloodstream because you're not gonna get
any masculinity or epic muscles like me
okay if you don't walk two steps at a
time I got little to zero respect for
you as a human being or I wouldn't even
call you that I would call the a lazy
Slava block that's what you are a blob
of goo a jelly bowl a bowl of jelly
which have no comprehension of society
you disgust me
walk down two steps at a time goddammit
and then and then I can look in the
freaking eyes now why am I saying this
all the sudden yeah because a new
science study came out of this do you
think I'm just giving out gibberish and
pseudoscience just for the sake of memes
and just for the sake of my political
argument I laughed I laughed I lament I
laughed
how about this thing huh a science babe
in October 6 2006 you get up the stairs
fasiq honestly try to refute this lib
tards people who walk on stairs two
steps at a time what do you do with a
free time you like developing muscle
strength huh look at your legs you might
as well have toothpicks as legs there is
one problem though there is one flaw
with this I will admit when there's an
odd number of shakers you can change
your life today too
all you gotta do is walk two steps at a
time it's not that hard okay
that was that was mean really sweet
Betsy
make review everybody hope you enjoyed
the beat hope you had fun hope you learn
something new today
smash like from a menu thumb Stamper 46
bye